destrabar las negociaciones entre el
gobierno de Venezuela y la oposición
estancada desde 2021 ese era el objetivo
de la Cumbre que se realizó en Bogotá
con presencia de 20 países el ministro
de exteriores de Colombia Álvaro Leiva
precisó las posiciones comunes se
identificaron posiciones comunes en
torno a los siguientes temas
uno
la necesidad de Establecer un cronograma
electoral que permita la celebración de
elecciones libres transparentes y con
plenas garantías para todos los actores
venezolanos
de los pasos acordados a satisfacción de
las partes
vayan en paralelo con el levantamiento
de las distintas sanciones pero mientras
en Bogotá se discutió un levantamiento
progresivo en las sanciones el gobierno
de maduro insistió en que primero les
quiten los límites económicos para luego
seguir la conversación Venezuela reitera
la necesidad de que sean levantadas
todas y cada una de las medidas
coercitivas unilaterales y legales y
lesivas del derecho internacional que
constituyen una agresión a toda la
población venezolana
Leiva también dijo que las negociaciones
en México deben continuar de la mano de
la implementación del fondo fiduciario
único administrado por la ONU para
inversión social en Venezuela las
decisiones de la conferencia serán
compartidas con el presidente venezolano
Nicolás maduro y con la oposición
ninguna de las partes participó en el
diálogo en Bogotá la reunión fue
realizada por iniciativa del presidente
colombiano Gustavo Petro Ojalá todo
comenzara por el reingreso de Venezuela
al sistema interamericano de Derechos
Humanos porque al final somos los
latinoamericanos los que tenemos que
decidir si vamos hacia la democracia o
hacia la guerra y la confrontación otro
de los puntos de la Cumbre fue la visita
del líder opositor Juan guaidó quien
primero llegó a Colombia y luego viajó a
Miami sin participar en la conferencia
según la cancillería el venezolano
ingresó a Colombia de manera irregular